let me ask another ridiculous question
i promise i think this might be the last
ridiculous question but
i doubt it i i aspire to ask as many
uh ridiculous questions of uh of a
brilliant mit
professor okay uh i don't know if you've
seen the
black mirror it's funny i i
never watched the episode i know when it
happened though
because i gave a talk to some mit
faculty
one day on a unassuming you know monday
or whatever i was telling him about the
state of robotics
and i showed some video of from boston
dynamics of the quadruped
spot at the time it was the early
version of spot
and there was a look of horror that went
across the room
and i said what you know i've i've shown
videos like this a lot of times
what happened and it turns out that this
video had gone yeah this black mirror
episode had changed the way people
watched
um yeah the videos i was putting out the
way they see these kinds of robots so
i talked to so many people who are just
terrified because of that episode
probably of these kinds of robots they
i almost want to say that you almost
kind of like enjoy being terrified
i don't even know what it is about human
psychology that kind of
imagine doomsday the destruction of the
universe
or our society and kind of
like enjoy being afraid um i don't want
to simplify it but it feels like
they talk about it so often it almost
there does seem to be an addictive
quality to it um i talked to a guy
that says this a guy named joe rogan
who's kind of the
flag bearer for being terrified of these
robots
do you have a two questions one do you
have an understanding of why people are
afraid
of robots and the second question is
in black mirror just to tell you the
episode i don't even remember it that
much
anymore but these robots i think they
can shoot like a
pellet or something they basically have
it's basically a spot with a gun
and um how far are we away from uh
having robots that go rogue like that
you know basically spot
that goes rogue for some reason
and somehow finds a gun right
so i mean i'm i'm not a psychologist
um i think i don't know exactly why
uh people react the way they do um
i think i think we have to be careful
about the way robots influence our
society and the like i think that's
something that's a responsibility that
roboticists
need to embrace um i don't think
robots are going to come after me with a
kitchen knife or a pellet gun
right away and i mean like if they were
programmed in such a way but
i used to joke with atlas that um
all i had to do was run for five minutes
and its battery would run out but uh
actually they've got a very big battery
in there by the end so it was over an
hour
um i think the fear is a bit cultural
though because i
i mean you notice that like i think
in my age in the us we grew up watching
terminator
right if i had grown up at the same time
in japan i probably would have been
watching astro boy
and there's a very different reaction to
robots
in different countries right so i don't
know if it's a human innate fear of
metal marvels or if it's um um
something that we've done to ourselves
with our sci-fi
uh yeah the stories we tell ourselves
through uh through movies through
just uh through popular media
but if if i were to tell you know if if
you were my therapist
and i said i'm really terrified that uh
we're going to have these robots very
soon that will hurt us
um like how do you approach
making me feel better um like
why shouldn't people be afraid there's a
i think there's a video that went viral
recently everything everything was spot
in boston damage goes viral in general
but usually it's like really cool stuff
like they're doing flips and stuff or
like sad stuff but
be it's atlas being hit with a
broomstick or something like that
but uh there's a video where i think uh
one of the new production spot robots
which are awesome
it was like patrolling somewhere in like
in some
country and like people immediately were
like
saying like this is like the dystopian
future
like the surveillance state for some
reason like you can just have
a camera like something about spot
being able to walk on four feet with
like really
terrified people so like what what do
you say
to those people i think there is a
legitimate fear there
because so much of our future is
uncertain
um but at the same time technically
speaking it seems like we're not there
yet
so what do you say i mean i think
technology
is um complicated it can be used in many
ways i think there are
purely software um
attacks that somebody could use to do
great damage
maybe they have already um you know i
think
uh wheeled robots
could be used in bad ways too
drones right um
i don't think that let's see
i don't want to be building technology
just
because i'm compelled to build
technology and i don't think about it
but i would consider myself a
technological optimist i guess
in the sense that i think we should
continue to
create and evolve and our world will
change um
and if we will introduce new challenges
we'll screw something up maybe but i
think also we'll
invent ourselves out of those challenges
and life will go on
so it's interesting because you didn't
mention like this is technically too
hard
i don't think robots are i think people
attribute a robot that looks like an
animal as maybe having a level of
self-awareness
or consciousness or something that they
don't have yet
right so it's not i think
our ability to anthropomorphize those
robots is probably
um we're assuming that they have a level
of intelligence that they don't yet have
and that might be part of the fear so in
that sense
it's too hard but um you know there are
many scary things in the world right so
i think we're right to ask those
questions we're right to
think about the implications of our work
right in the in this in the short term
as we're working on it for sure
is there something long term that
scares you about our future with ai and
robots a lot of folks
from elon musk to sam harris to
a lot of folks talk about the you know
existential threats about artificial
intelligence
oftentimes robots kind of inspire that
the most because of the anthropomorphism
do you have any fears
it's an important question
i actually i think i like rod brook's
answer maybe the best
on this i think and it's not the only
answer he's given over the years but
maybe one of my favorites is
um he says it's not going to be
he's got a book flesh and machines i
believe um
it's not going to be the robots versus
the people we're all going to be robot
people
because you know we already have
smartphones some of us have
serious technology implanted in our
bodies already whether we have a
hearing aid or a pacemaker or anything
like this
people with amputations might have
prosthetics
that's a trend i think that it's likely
to continue i mean this is now
uh wild speculation but uh
i mean when do we get to cognitive
implants and the like
and yeah with neural link brain computer
interfaces
that's interesting so there's a there's
a dance between humans and robots
it's going to be
it's going to be impossible to be scared
of
the other out there the robot because
the robot will be part of us
essentially he'd be so intricately sort
of part of our society
that and it might not even be implanted
part of us but just
it's so much a part of our yeah our
society
so in that sense the smartphone is
already the robot we should be afraid of
yeah uh i mean yeah and all the usual
fears arise
of the misinformation the
the manipulation all those kinds of
things
that um that
the problems are all the same they're
all they're human problems essentially
it feels like yeah i mean i think the
the way we interact with each other
online
is changing the value we put on you know
personal
interaction and that's a crazy big
change that's going to happen and rip
through our system has already been
ripping through our society right
and that has implications that are
massive i don't know if they should be
scared of it or just go with the flow
but
i don't see you know some battle lines
between humans and robots being
the first thing to worry about i mean i
do want to just
as a kind of comment maybe you can
comment about your just feelings about
boston dynamics in general
but you know i love science i love
engineering i think there's so many
beautiful ideas in it
and when i look at boston dynamics or
legged robots in general i think they
inspire
people curiosity
and feelings in general excitement
about engineering more than almost
anything else in popular culture
and i think that's such an exciting pos
like responsibility and possibility for
robotics
and boston dynamics is riding that wave
pretty damn well like
they've found it they've discovered that
hunger and
curiosity in the people and they're
doing magic with it
i don't care if the i mean i guess this
is their company they have to make money
right
but uh they're already doing incredible
work and inspiring the world about
technology
i mean do you have th do you have
thoughts about boston dynamics and maybe
others your own work and robotics and
inspiring the world in that way i
completely agree i think boston dynamics
is absolutely
awesome i think i show my kids those
videos you know and the best thing that
happens is sometimes they've already
seen them you know uh
right i think i i just think
it's a pinnacle of success in robotics
that
is just one of the best things that's
happened i absolutely completely agree
one of the heartbreaking things to me is
how many
robotics companies fail
how hard it is to make money with the
robotics company
like irobot like went through hell
just to arrive at a roomba yeah to
figure out one product
and then there's so many um home
robotics companies like uh
jibo and uh
anki anki
the cutest toy there's a great robot i
thought uh went down
i'm forgetting a bunch of them but a
bunch of robotics rods company
rethink robotics um
like do you um do you have any
anything hopeful to say about the
possibility of making money with robots
oh i think um you can't just look at the
failures you can all i mean boston
dynamics is a success there's lots of
companies that are still
doing amazingly good um work in robotics
i mean this is the this is the
capitalist
ecology or something right i think you
have many companies you have many
startups and they
push each other forward and many of them
fail and some of them get through and
that's sort of
the natural way of things the way of
those things i don't know that
is robotics really that much worse i
feel the pain that you feel too every
time i read
one of these i sometimes it's friends
and and uh
i definitely wish it went better or
would differently
but i think it's healthy and good to
have um bursts of ideas burst of
activities
ideas if they are really aggressive they
should fail sometimes
um certainly that's the research mantra
right if you're
succeeding at every problem you attempt
then you're not
choosing aggressively enough is it
exciting to you uh the new spot
oh it's okay it's so good what are you
getting him as a pet
uh it yeah i mean i have to dig up 75k
right now it's so cool that there's a
price tag you can go
and and then actually buy it and i have
a skydio r1
uh love it so um
no i would i would i would absolutely be
a customer uh
i wonder what your kids would think
about i i actually um
zach from boston dynamics would let my
kid drive in one of their demos one time
and uh that was just so good uh
so good and again forever be grateful
for that
and there's something magical about the
anthropomorphization of that arm
it adds another level of human
connection
i'm not sure we understand from a
control
aspect the value of anthropomorphization
i think that's an understudied and
understood
engineering problem there's been a
psycho like psychologists have been
studying it
i think it's part like manipulating our
mind to believe things
uh is a valuable engineering like this
is another degree of
freedom that can be controlled i like
that yeah i think that's right i think
you know there's something that humans
seem to do or maybe my
dangerous introspection is uh
i think we are able to make very simple
models that
assume a lot about the world very
quickly
and then uh it takes us a lot more time
like you're wrestling you know you
probably
thought you knew what you're doing with
wrestling and you were fairly functional
as a complete wrestler
and then you slowly got more expertise
so maybe
uh it's natural that our first
first level of defense against seeing a
new robot is to think of it
in our existing models of how humans and
animals behave
and it's just as you spend more time
with it then you'll develop more
sophisticated models that will
appreciate the differences
you